This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last fall, the BBC made a huge announcement. They had picked a new lead actor for their beloved TV show, Doctor Who. Hello, I'm Shuty Gatswa, and I am the next doctor in the next season of Doctor Who. If you need some context, a new lead actor on Doctor Who is like a new pope being selected. But for nerds! That's producer Chris Baroube. This announcement should have been a triumphant moment.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。去年秋天，BBC发布了一个重磅消息。他们为备受喜爱的电视剧《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）选定了一位新的主演。你好，我是舒提·盖特瓦（Ncuti Gatwa），我将是下一季《神秘博士》中的下一任博士。如果你需要一点背景知识，《神秘博士》选定新主演就像选出新教皇一样。只不过是针对书呆子们的！那是制片人克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）。这个公告本应是一个胜利的时刻。
After all, the actor Chuty Gatwa was the first black performer cast as the doctor. But when this video came out, the announcement was quickly overshadowed by something that should have been totally mundane. The closed captions. Gat was first name spelled NCUTI, but the closed captions on YouTube replaced his name with a swear word. So while the actor said, hello, I'm Shiti Gatsova. The captions auto corrected his name to, hello, I'm Shiti Gatsov.
毕竟，演员舒提·盖特瓦是第一位被选为博士的黑人演员。但当这段视频发布时，这个公告很快就被一件本应完全平凡的事情所掩盖了。隐藏式字幕。盖特瓦的名字拼写是NCUTI，但YouTube上的隐藏式字幕却把他的名字替换成了一个脏话。所以当演员说“你好，我是舒提·盖特瓦”时，字幕自动纠正他的名字为“你好，我是Shiti Gatsov”。
That was unfortunate, but it was far from an isolated incident. When you start looking for closed caption failures, you see them pretty much everywhere. I turned on closed captions for a week on broadcast TV, YouTube, pretty much anywhere I was watching stuff, and I noticed so many errors. The fictional country and Black Panther, Wakanda, it became War, Canada. Bill Murray and Dan Ackroyd were suddenly part of an elite group called The Ghost Busses. It went on and on. There's actually an academic high-minded term to describe this phenomenon. Crapchens are captions that are crappy.
这很不幸，但这绝非孤立事件。当你开始寻找隐藏式字幕的故障时，你会发现它们几乎无处不在。我在广播电视、YouTube以及我观看内容的任何地方开启了一周的隐藏式字幕，我注意到了太多的错误。《黑豹》中的虚构国家瓦坎达（Wakanda）变成了“战争，加拿大”（War, Canada）。比尔·默瑞（Bill Murray）和丹·艾克罗伊德（Dan Aykroyd）突然成为了一个名为“幽灵巴士”（The Ghost Busses）的精英组织成员。这种情况层出不穷。实际上，有一个学术性的高雅术语来描述这种现象。“Crapchens”就是指那些糟糕的字幕（crappy captions）。
That's Linda Bessner. She wrote about captions for the Atlantic magazine, and she says there are many, many ways a caption can be crappy. They are not accurate. They don't differentiate between speakers, so it's just one long run on sentence. It's not grammatically correct.
那是琳达·贝斯纳（Linda Besner）。她为《大西洋》杂志撰写过关于字幕的文章，她说字幕变糟糕的方式有很多很多种。它们不准确。它们无法区分说话者，所以只是一长串连在一起的句子。它们在语法上不正确。
It doesn't contain punctuation. So they are sort of halfway there captions Look bad closed captions can be really funny But captions are a critical tool for lots and lots of people There's people learning a new language People like me who for the life of me cannot understand the Irish accents on dairy girls. And of course, captions are essential for people who are deaf and hard of hearing. In the United States, that's about 15% of the adult population. And with so many captions out there, those folks are often left trying to piece together
它们不包含标点符号。所以它们算是半吊子字幕。糟糕的隐藏式字幕可能真的很有趣，但字幕对于很多人来说是一个关键工具。有正在学习新语言的人，有像我这样无论如何都听不懂《德里女孩》（Derry Girls）中爱尔兰口音的人。当然，字幕对于聋哑人和听障人士来说是必不可少的。在美国，这大约占成年人口的15%。由于字幕太多，这些人往往只能试着拼凑
meaning from some bizarre sentences or to just stop watching. The issue of crappy captions isn't a new thing. Activists have been fighting for accurate widespread closed captioning for decades, and it's not clear when, if ever, they will become a reality. Bad captions aren't just annoying. They're supposed to be illegal, at least for television. In America, the FCC is responsible for making sure the airwaves are accessible for everybody. And since 1996, they've required all TV shows to include
从一些奇怪的句子中理解含义，或者干脆停止观看。糟糕字幕的问题并不是什么新鲜事。几十年来，活动家们一直在争取准确、广泛的隐藏式字幕，而且目前还不清楚这种情况何时（如果真的会发生的话）能成为现实。糟糕的字幕不仅仅是令人讨厌。它们本应是非法的，至少对于电视来说是这样。在美国，联邦通信委员会（FCC）负责确保广播对每个人都是无障碍的。自1996年以来，他们要求所有电视节目必须包含
captions that are, quote, accurate, synchronous, complete, and properly placed. Broadcasters in the United States also have to comply with guidelines under the Americans with Disabilities Act, which was passed in 1990. The ADA says all businesses that serve the public or places a public accommodation must be equally available to everyone, which means broadcast CV needs to be accessible for the deaf and hard of hearing. Taken together, the FCC and ADA rules were pretty clear. For TV, you need to caption. And you need to caption well.
“准确、同步、完整且放置得当”的字幕。美国的广播公司还必须遵守1990年通过的《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）下的指导方针。ADA规定，所有服务公众的企业或公共场所必须对每个人平等开放，这意味着广播电视需要对聋哑人和听障人士无障碍。综合来看，FCC和ADA的规则非常明确。对于电视，你需要提供字幕。而且你需要提供高质量的字幕。
And for a while, those rules were enough, until the rise of streaming TV. Howard Rosenbloom is the CEO of the National Association of the Deaf, or the NAD. Howard himself is deaf, and we interviewed him over Zoom with the assistance of an ASL interpreter. Throughout this story, you'll hear her voice representing his answers. Here he comes. There we go, he says, hello, Chris.
有一段时间，这些规则已经足够了，直到流媒体电视的兴起。霍华德·罗森布鲁姆（Howard Rosenblum）是美国全国聋人协会（NAD）的首席执行官。霍华德本人是聋人，我们在美国手语（ASL）翻译的协助下通过Zoom采访了他。在整个故事中，你将听到她的声音代表他的回答。他来了。好了，他说，你好，克里斯。
Howard points to 2007 as the first time the NAD got involved in captions for streaming when Netflix launched its on-demand service. At the time, if you recall, it was the era of DVDs in the postal mail, right? Ironically, there was no law which required DVDs to be captioned. But I would say roughly But I would say roughly 85 to 90% of them were. So many of the members of NAD were Netflix subscribers. We'd get our DVDs in the postal mail and it was all good. Netflix decided then to pivot to streaming.
霍华德指出2007年是NAD首次介入流媒体字幕的时候，当时Netflix推出了其点播服务。如果你还记得的话，当时是邮寄DVD的时代，对吧？讽刺的是，当时没有法律要求DVD必须有字幕。但我会说大约85%到90%的DVD都有字幕。所以NAD的许多成员都是Netflix的用户。我们通过邮寄收到DVD，一切都很好。Netflix当时决定转向流媒体。
However, streaming at the time, there was almost none. Maybe 10% of them were captioned. Howard and the NAD approached Netflix about this issue, but at the time, Netflix argued the rules didn't apply to them. They weren't television, so they weren't under the jurisdiction of the FCC. And Netflix argued the ADA didn't apply to them either. Here's writer Linda Besner again. Title III of the ADA says that that in places of public accommodation,
然而，当时的流媒体几乎没有字幕。可能只有10%的内容有字幕。霍华德和NAD就这个问题接触了Netflix，但当时Netflix辩称这些规则不适用于他们。他们不是电视，所以不在FCC的管辖范围内。而且Netflix辩称ADA也不适用于他们。这是作家琳达·贝斯纳。ADA的第三章规定，在公共场所，
deaf and hard of hearing people must be accommodated, so they should have an experience equal to that of a person who is not deaf or hard of hearing. Netflix's argument was, we are not subject to the ADA because we're not a place. They were like, well, we are not an amusement park or like, you know, some kind of public forum. We're not a physical location,
必须为聋哑人和听障人士提供便利，因此他们应该获得与非聋哑或听障人士平等的体验。Netflix的论点是，我们不受ADA约束，因为我们不是一个“场所”。他们说，好吧，我们不是游乐园或者某种公共论坛。我们不是一个物理位置，
so we don't have to do this. The National Association of the Deaf argued that, okay, sure, Netflix is not a physical place, but isn't it kind of a social place? You know, what about a family watching a Netflix show together? Like, this is a social experience. Why should there be a member of that family who is excluded from that content?
所以我们不必这样做。全国聋人协会辩称，好吧，当然，Netflix不是一个物理场所，但它难道不是一个社交场所吗？你知道，一家人一起看Netflix节目呢？这是一种社交体验。为什么家庭中应该有一名成员被排除在内容之外呢？
In 2011, the NAD sued Netflix in a Massachusetts court that judge agreed that the ADA applies to Netflix and issued a consent decree saying Netflix had to provide captions for all of its streaming content within four years. Today, the full Netflix library is captioned. They have teams of captioners working on every show, and some of their captions are really good, and some of them are only okay, but according to Howard Rosenblum of the NAD, Netflix has done a fairly good job.
2011年，NAD在马萨诸塞州法院起诉了Netflix，法官同意ADA适用于Netflix，并发布了一项同意令，要求Netflix在四年内为其所有流媒体内容提供字幕。今天，Netflix的整个库都有字幕。他们有专门的字幕团队为每个节目工作，他们的一些字幕非常好，一些只是还可以，但根据NAD的霍华德·罗森布鲁姆的说法，Netflix做得相当不错。
Once that case was done and dusted, we began to approach other companies like Hulu, Amazon. So all three of them agreed to the terms of a phased in captioning approach. Since the Netflix case, the National Association of the Deaf has been playing a game of whack-a-mole with the internet. Basically, a new streaming thing will crop up, and the NAD will helpfully remind them about their legal requirements to caption stuff. The NAD has worked with companies like Zoom and Microsoft Teams to encourage live captions for online meetings, and in 2015, the NAD sued Harvard and MIT for not providing captions for their online courses. Most recently, the NAD sued serious exam
一旦那个案件尘埃落定，我们开始接触其他公司，比如Hulu、亚马逊。所以这三家公司都同意了分阶段实施字幕的方法。自Netflix案以来，全国聋人协会一直在互联网上玩“打地鼠”游戏。基本上，一个新的流媒体平台出现，NAD就会好心地提醒他们关于字幕的法律要求。NAD曾与Zoom和微软Teams等公司合作，鼓励在线会议提供实时字幕，并在2015年，NAD起诉了哈佛大学和麻省理工学院，因为他们没有为在线课程提供字幕。最近，NAD起诉了SiriusXM
for not providing transcripts on their podcasts. Nearly all podcasts are recorded, right? They're not live. There's no excuse for not providing a transcript. Full disclosure here, 99PI is owned by a serious exam, but I'll note that our show does provide transcripts to all of our episodes. While there's been a lot of progress on the issue of streaming captions, there's one internet galaeth the NAD won't go after. It's actually a place used
因为没有为他们的播客提供文字记录。几乎所有的播客都是录制好的，对吧？它们不是直播的。没有理由不提供文字记录。这里披露一下，99PI归SiriusXM所有，但我会指出，我们的节目确实为我们所有的剧集提供了文字记录。虽然在流媒体字幕问题上取得了很大进展，但互联网上有一个NAD不会去触碰的巨头。它实际上是一个被
by 80% of Americans, where people watch billions of hours of content every day. I'm talking about YouTube. Linda Bezner spoke to YouTube about this problem a couple of years ago. And back then, they made it clear. They had no plans to require captions for all of their videos. Here's Linda. They did say, for example, for things like sort of live citizen journalism. Like the spokesperson I spoke with gave the example of Arab Spring. You know, if it's somebody who is, you know, posting video of some event that is occurring
80%的美国人使用的地方，人们每天在那里观看数十亿小时的内容。我说的是YouTube。琳达·贝斯纳几年前就这个问题与YouTube谈过。当时，他们说得很清楚。他们没有计划要求所有视频都提供字幕。这是琳达。他们确实说，例如，对于像某种实时公民新闻。就像我采访的发言人举的“阿拉伯之春”的例子。你知道，如果有人在发布正在发生的某个事件的视频，
around them, are you really going to flag for removal that video because it doesn't have transcriptions? Even though YouTube isn't legally required to provide closed captions, they have a lot of deaf and hard of hearing users. In 2009, YouTube tried addressing the transcriptions. The automatic captions are created with Google's universal speech model, which uses speech recognition technology and AI to identify words, and then put them together into coherent sentences. Predictive text is something that, you know, you may be familiar with from autocorrect on your phone, that it's like you started a sentence, and then it wants to fill in your blank.
你真的会因为那个视频没有文字记录而标记删除它吗？尽管YouTube在法律上不需要提供隐藏式字幕，但他们有很多聋哑和听障用户。2009年，YouTube尝试解决文字记录问题。自动字幕是使用谷歌的通用语音模型创建的，该模型使用语音识别技术和人工智能来识别单词，然后将它们组合成连贯的句子。预测性文本是你可能从手机自动更正中熟悉的东西，就像你开始了一个句子，然后它想要填补你的空白。
Much like maybe your mother does. And much like your mother, sometimes they don't know what you are going to say, and you have to be like, wow, that's not like, I'm not, I'm actually trying to make the opposite point right now. The early days of automatic captions were pretty rough. And Ricky pointer remembers them well. Ricky is a deaf YouTuber. And in 2009, she was watching a lot of beauty videos using the brand new automatic captions. I remember I was watching a video about concealers and the automatic captions I had them on and
就像你母亲可能做的那样。而且就像你母亲一样，有时他们不知道你要说什么，你不得不说，哇，那不是，我不是，我实际上现在正试图表达相反的观点。自动字幕的早期阶段相当粗糙。瑞奇·波因特（Ricky Pointer）对此记忆犹新。瑞奇是一位聋人YouTuber。2009年，她正在使用全新的自动字幕观看很多美妆视频。我记得我当时在看一个关于遮瑕膏的视频，我打开了自动字幕，
they were saying zebra, the mammal, the animal, whatever, in place of the word concealers, which was so bizarre. Ricky started her YouTube career making videos about makeup and beauty products, but she wanted to do something different. So in 2014, Ricky produced a video called Things You Shouldn't Say to People Who Are Deaf or Heart of Hearing, where she lamppoons the clueless questions she was always being asked by hearing folks. It's deafness contagious.
它们用“斑马”（zebra，哺乳动物，动物，随便什么）代替了“遮瑕膏”（concealers）这个词，这太奇怪了。瑞奇开始她的YouTube生涯是制作关于化妆和美容产品的视频，但她想做一些不同的事情。因此，在2014年，瑞奇制作了一个名为《你不应该对聋哑或听障人士说的话》的视频，她在视频中讽刺了她总是被听力正常的人问到的无知问题。耳聋会传染吗？
I don't know, but come over here. I'll call for you and we'll find out tomorrow. Why don't you know sign language? You must not really beat it. Well, last time I checked, deafness has to do with whether or not your eardwork and not the languages that you know. A couple of Ricky's videos focused on the issue of closed captioning. And in one video, Ricky made a call to arms, asking her fellow YouTubers to ditch automatic captions and write their own captions instead, for better yet, to hire a professional service
我不知道，但过来这里。我会为你呼叫，我们明天就会知道。你为什么不会手语？你一定不是真的耳聋。好吧，上次我检查时，耳聋与你的耳朵是否工作有关，而不是与你所知道的语言有关。瑞奇的几个视频关注了隐藏式字幕的问题。在一个视频中，瑞奇发出了号召，要求她的YouTuber同行们放弃自动字幕，转而编写自己的字幕，或者更好的是，聘请专业服务
to make the captions for them. The campaign for human closed captions went viral, and Ricky caught the attention of some of YouTube's biggest stars. I want to make my little community here on YouTube more inclusive, and one of the ways that I have decided to do that in the new year is by close captioning every single one of my videos. Yeah, Tyler agreed me to video.
为他们制作字幕。人类制作字幕的运动走红了，瑞奇引起了一些YouTube最大明星的注意。我想让我在YouTube上的这个小社区更具包容性，我在新的一年里决定这样做的方法之一就是为我的每一个视频添加隐藏式字幕。是的，泰勒同意了我的视频。
While I was on a plane on the way to LA, actually, and it was like titled, Hear Me Out or something, and I was in the thumbnail, and he was talking about the importance of captions, and I had no idea. Until I had landed in a letter on my phone and I was getting so many notifications. Today, Oakley's video about closed captions has been watched more than 1.8 million times. And after that, other big-time YouTubers weighed in, like Lily Singh.
当时我正在去洛杉矶的飞机上，标题是《听我说完》之类的，我在缩略图中，他正在谈论字幕的重要性，我完全不知道。直到我降落，手机里收到一封信，我收到了太多的通知。今天，奥克利的关于隐藏式字幕的视频已经被观看了超过180万次。在那之后，其他大牌YouTuber也发表了意见，比如莉莉·辛格（Lilly Singh）。
But Ricky Poyter wanted to push the campaign into a higher gear. So in 2016, she launched a hashtag called No More Craptions. The term had been floating around the internet for a while, but Ricky helped bring it to the mainstream. Lots of YouTubers, both deaf and hearing, made videos pledging to include human-produced captions in their videos. Close captions help the deaf in the heart of hearing.
但瑞奇·波因特想把这场运动推向更高的档次。因此，在2016年，她发起了一个名为“不再有烂字幕”（No More Craptions）的标签。这个词在互联网上流传了一段时间，但瑞奇帮助它进入了主流。许多YouTuber，无论是聋人还是听力正常的人，都制作了视频，承诺在他们的视频中包含人工制作的字幕。隐藏式字幕帮助了聋哑人和听障人士。
Hello. Today's video is about the No More Crapchens campaign. Why isn't this video closed captioned when it's labeled closed captioned? And I was freaking out because there's some big beauty creators that had my announcements that they were gonna start captioning and then it was start captioning you know a couple of videos at a time. Things were getting better human captions were showing up on more and more videos until some YouTubers just stopped doing it. Ricky says it was disappointing to see many YouTubers stop captioning their videos. There's no mystery as to why this happened.
你好。今天的视频是关于“不再有烂字幕”运动的。为什么这个视频被标记为有隐藏式字幕却没提供？我当时快疯了，因为有一些大的美妆创作者宣布他们将开始添加字幕，然后他们开始一次添加几个视频的字幕。情况正在好转，人工字幕出现在越来越多的视频上，直到一些YouTuber停止了这样做。瑞奇说，看到许多YouTuber停止为他们的视频添加字幕令人失望。这发生的原因并不神秘。
Do it yourself captions can be time consuming. Meanwhile, hiring a professional to make your closed captions can be expensive. Professional captioners on the whole, they aren't paid very well. But for a YouTuber, dropping 40 or $50 to caption a video, can add up pretty quickly. Look, captioning videos at a professional level is hard work. Oh, I got headaches. Yeah. And like, yeah, my eyes, I mean, my vision is not great anyway, but it was, it was pretty bad for all that stuff. My friend Emma Healy started work as a close captioner in Toronto in 2017. The company that I was working for had been subcontracted out by an Australian broadcasting company, so I was captioning with Australian broadcasting rules.
自己动手制作字幕可能很耗时。与此同时，聘请专业人士制作隐藏式字幕可能很昂贵。总的来说，专业字幕员的报酬并不高。但对于YouTuber来说，花40或50美元为视频添加字幕，很快就会积少成多。看，在专业水平上为视频添加字幕是艰苦的工作。哦，我头疼。是的。而且，我的视力本来就不好，但对于所有这些事情来说，这真的很糟糕。我的朋友艾玛·希利（Emma Healy）于2017年在多伦多开始担任隐藏式字幕员。我工作的公司被一家澳大利亚广播公司分包了，所以我使用的是澳大利亚广播规则来制作字幕。
For this job, Emma had to watch a lot of crappy TV. A big one that people would complain about was Crocomoli, which was an Australian children's television show about a crocodile that loved guacamole named Crocamole. I gotta be honest, our interview devolved into watching Crocamole for like half an hour. It's not the most lyric we invented. This is the first thought best thought. His eyes are really sad. Even though Emma was captioning some pretty simple TV shows, the work took a very long time.
为了这份工作，艾玛不得不看很多糟糕的电视节目。人们抱怨最多的一个节目是《Crocamole》，这是一个关于一只喜欢鳄梨酱的鳄梨酱鳄鱼的澳大利亚儿童电视节目。我得诚实地说，我们的采访演变成了看半小时的《Crocamole》。这不是我们发明的最抒情的。这是第一想法，最好的想法。他的眼睛真的很悲伤。尽管艾玛在为一些非常简单的电视节目制作字幕，但这项工作花费了很长时间。
Emma says she would do about 40 minutes of captioning in an eight hour shift. And that was on a good day. The place that I was working there was, I believe, a 75-page manual full of rules. All very technical and you had to memorize basically all of them. Emma showed me the manual, which outlines the rules for how captions are supposed to look on Australian broadcast TV. And it made professional captioning seem impossibly Byzantine. Here we go. Minimum duration is one second. No maximum, but seven to eight seconds is typical.
艾玛说她在八小时的轮班中大约能完成40分钟的字幕。那还是在顺利的一天。我工作的地方，我相信有一本75页的规则手册。非常技术性，你基本上必须背诵所有这些规则。艾玛给我看了这本手册，它概述了澳大利亚广播电视上字幕应该如何显示的规则。这让专业字幕制作看起来极其复杂。我们开始吧。最短持续时间是一秒。没有最大值，但七到八秒是典型的。
Do not leave captions on screen overly long for no reason if the dialogue has ended. There must be a one second blank caption. It goes on like this. For 75 pages. Emma had to keep all of this stuff in mind for what was ultimately a minimum wage job. Professional captioning is complicated because it's not just about getting the words right. You also
如果对话已经结束，不要无缘无故地让字幕留在屏幕上太久。必须有一个一秒钟的空白字幕。它就这样持续下去。长达75页。艾玛必须记住所有这些东西，而这最终只是一份最低工资的工作。专业字幕制作很复杂，因为这不仅仅是把单词写对。你还
have to nail the punctuation and the placement of the caption and lots of other small details. Here's Linda Besner. So the gold standard for closed captioning would be something where, you know, for example you and I are talking. When I am talking, it might say Linda Colin. And then there would be a capital letter to indicate that I am beginning a sentence. And then it would faithfully represent what I have said with question marks
必须搞定标点符号、字幕的位置以及许多其他小细节。这是琳达·贝斯纳。所以隐藏式字幕的黄金标准是这样的，例如你和我正在交谈。当我说话时，它可能会说“琳达：”。然后会有一个大写字母来表示我正在开始一个句子。然后它会忠实地呈现我说过的话，并在
where I have asked a question and commas, where commas go. When there is, one of the cats makes a noise in the background. There would be square brackets cat meowing. If a violent windstorm swept over and you could hear, you know, raindrops coming against the window, it would have bracket raindrops sweep against window pain. So this kind of caption really gives you the feeling that you are, you are privy to anything in the auditory environment of that video. YouTube creators could either hire a professional captioner, which is expensive, or do this work
我提出问题的地方加上问号，在逗号该出现的地方加上逗号。当其中一只猫在背景中发出声音时。会有方括号“猫叫声”。如果一场猛烈的风暴席卷而来，你可以听到雨点打在窗户上，它会有方括号“雨点扫过窗玻璃”。所以这种字幕真的让你感觉你了解该视频听觉环境中的任何事物。YouTube创作者要么聘请专业字幕员，这很昂贵，要么自己做这项工作
themselves which can take a long time for a beginner. So a lot of them just don't bother. Since Ricky's campaign, there have been signs of progress. According to YouTube, in the past few years, there's actually been an increase in the number of human captions submitted by creators. From 2020 to 2021, the number of videos with manual captions on YouTube went up by 30%. But despite this uptick, let's think about the bigger picture here. Automatic captions are still by far the most common type of caption on the platform. To this day, YouTube has no plans to require human-generated captions on their videos. And the NAD has said it has no plans to sue YouTube.
这对于初学者来说可能需要很长时间。所以很多人干脆就不费那个劲了。自瑞奇的运动以来，已经有了进步的迹象。据YouTube称，在过去几年里，创作者提交的人工字幕数量实际上有所增加。从2020年到2021年，YouTube上手动字幕视频的数量增加了30%。但尽管有这种增长，让我们考虑一下这里的大局。自动字幕仍然是该平台上最常见的字幕类型。时至今日，YouTube没有计划要求其视频必须有自动生成的字幕。而NAD表示没有计划起诉YouTube。
Legally speaking, Howard Rosenblum doesn't think the NAD can make an argument that YouTube is covered by the ADA. Also, Howard believes it would be incredibly difficult to caption everything on the site. For YouTube, we do work closely, for example, with Google who owns YouTube. And we've talked through this issue. And there are two separate problems at play,
从法律上讲，霍华德·罗森布鲁姆认为NAD无法提出YouTube受ADA管辖的论点。此外，霍华德认为为网站上的所有内容添加字幕将极其困难。对于YouTube，我们确实密切合作，例如与拥有YouTube的谷歌。我们已经讨论过这个问题。而且有两个独立的问题在起作用，
one of which is the working retroactively on the millions of minutes of content that is already uploaded to YouTube. Stagger's the imagination. The second issue is the huge amount of new content that's uploaded every day. I don't remember the number of hours of videos posted to YouTube every minute, but it's mind boggling. YouTube has experimented with ways to encourage more human captioning. In 2018, they introduced a program called Community Captions where volunteers could submit captions for popular videos. Many deaf YouTubers like the program, but it was discontinued in 2020,
其中之一是追溯处理已经上传到YouTube的数百万分钟的内容。这超出了想象。第二个问题是每天上传的大量新内容。我不记得每分钟发布到YouTube的视频小时数，但这令人难以置信。YouTube尝试了鼓励更多人工字幕的方法。2018年，他们推出了一个名为“社区字幕”的项目，志愿者可以为热门视频提交字幕。许多聋人YouTuber喜欢这个项目，但它在2020年被取消了，
because many of the volunteer captioners were submitting jokes or promotional material instead of accurate captions. When I reached out to YouTube, they pointed to a couple of new programs they're rolling out to help people with captioning. One allows users to give subtitle editors permission to fix up their captions. Another allows you to submit corrections if you see in an accurate caption on certain videos. But ultimately, it feels like YouTube is putting all of its chips on AI to fill in the caption gap. Just let the automatic captions continue improving until they get closer to total accuracy.
因为许多志愿者字幕员提交的是笑话或宣传材料，而不是准确的字幕。当我联系YouTube时，他们指出了他们正在推出的几个帮助人们制作字幕的新项目。一个允许用户给字幕编辑权限来修复他们的字幕。另一个允许你在某些视频上看到不准确的字幕时提交更正。但最终，感觉YouTube正在把所有的筹码都押在人工智能上，以填补字幕空白。让自动字幕继续改进，直到它们接近完全准确。
To be fair, the automatic captions have gotten a lot better. YouTube would not share accuracy numbers for this story, but according to the media hub at the University of Minnesota at Duluth, YouTube auto captions are somewhere around 70 percent accurate. That's a big improvement from the early days. Ricky Pointer says she's noticed the difference. AI captions still don't include contextual things like the rain is falling softly in the background against the window pane. But the AI has become very good at identifying dialogue. I were to say, you know, dentist recommend daily fossing to help remove decay causing material from between teeth and undergums.
公平地说，自动字幕已经好多了。YouTube没有为这个故事分享准确率数据，但根据明尼苏达大学德卢斯分校的媒体中心，YouTube自动字幕的准确率大约在70%左右。这比早期有了很大的进步。瑞奇·波因特说她注意到了这种差异。人工智能字幕仍然不包含上下文内容，比如雨水在窗玻璃背景下轻轻落下。但人工智能在识别对话方面变得非常擅长。如果我要说，你知道，牙医建议每天使用牙线来帮助清除牙齿之间和牙龈下的腐烂物质。
The automatic captions would be able to write that out wordwise. Usually, really pretty well. There are still some major problems. The auto captions haven't figured out. Grammar remains an issue. And the AI is pretty good with words in English, but it really struggles with other languages, especially when it comes to names and places. This is a pretty common complaint words in English, but it really struggles with other languages, especially when it comes to names and places.
自动字幕通常能够非常准确地逐字写出来。仍然存在一些主要问题。自动字幕还没有弄清楚。语法仍然是一个问题。而且人工智能对英语单词非常擅长，但它在其他语言上真的很吃力，特别是在涉及人名和地名时。这是一个非常普遍的抱怨。
This is a pretty common complaint about AI programs, the way they can adopt certain biases. And there's another issue with the captions produced by AI. Many users find them hard to read. They move in a more like kinetic, I think that's the term I learned like a week ago. Kinetic way where it sounds like words are coming like this. They show up one word at a time. And that's not the most accessible way to follow. Still, despite the challenges and the frequent wonkiness, automatic captions just keep getting better. And they will keep improving.
这是关于人工智能程序的一个非常普遍的抱怨，它们采用某些偏见的方式。而且人工智能产生的字幕还有另一个问题。许多用户发现它们很难阅读。它们以一种更像动力学的方式移动，我想这是我一周前学到的术语，听起来单词是这样出来的。它们一次显示一个单词。而且这不是跟随字幕最无障碍的方式。尽管有挑战和频繁的古怪，自动字幕还是在不断变好。而且它们会继续改进。
I mean, have you been following the terrifying progress of AI recently? There's an AI program now, good enough to pass the bar exam. So how hard are closed captions? Howard Rosenblum thinks the AI captions will compete with human captioners a lot faster than we think.
我的意思是，你最近一直在关注人工智能可怕的进步吗？现在有一个人工智能程序，好到足以通过律师资格考试。那么隐藏式字幕有多难呢？霍华德·罗森布鲁姆认为人工智能字幕与人类字幕员竞争的速度比我们想象的要快得多。
Five years ago, I would have said, A, no way. There is no way ASR is going to get anywhere. But now, like, it's shocking how much better it's gotten. In 5 years, who even knows? I suspect it will be better. Maybe it will be less than 5 years. To me, it feels very possible the automatic captions will get close to 100% accuracy, at
五年前，我会说，不，没门。自动语音识别（ASR）不可能有任何进展。但现在，它变得好多了，这令人震惊。五年后，谁知道呢？我怀疑它会更好。也许不到五年。对我来说，自动字幕接近100%的准确率感觉非常有可能，
least for speech. But even if we can get there, the fact is we aren't there yet, and deaf and hard-of-hearing people have real accessibility needs right now. People like Ricky Pointer. I mean, what I love for automatic captions to be 100% absolutely, but I just, it's hard to know if that's ever gonna be possible. Maybe in the year 3000. I don't wanna wait years and years and years and years for that to happen.
至少对于语音来说是这样。但即使我们能做到这一点，事实是我们还没有做到，而且聋哑和听障人士现在就有真正的无障碍需求。像瑞奇·波因特这样的人。我的意思是，我希望自动字幕能达到100%绝对准确，但我只是，很难知道这是否真的可能。也许在3000年。我不想等上几年又几年又几年才让这种情况发生。
Ricky doesn't go on YouTube much anymore. Not because of accessibility, it's because, frankly, she feels like she's growing out of it. A lot of her friends have left. It doesn't feel like such a special community these days. Still, once in a while, Ricky checks in on her favorite accounts, and recently, she saw one of her favorite creators had published her first video after a long hiatus. Charlie McDonnell, Charlie is so cool like she came back to YouTube. first video after a long hiatus. Ricky was excited to watch the video, but as always she was dreading the automatic captions. To Ricky's surprise, the video had human captions.
瑞奇现在不怎么上YouTube了。不是因为无障碍问题，而是因为，坦率地说，她觉得她正在长大，不再适合它了。她的许多朋友都离开了。这些天它感觉不再是一个特别的社区了。不过，偶尔，瑞奇会查看她最喜欢的账户，最近，她看到她最喜欢的创作者之一在长期中断后发布了她的第一个视频。查理·麦克唐纳（Charlie McDonnell），查理太酷了，她回到了YouTube。瑞奇很兴奋地观看视频，但像往常一样，她害怕自动字幕。令瑞奇惊讶的是，视频有人工字幕。
They weren't totally professional, it looked like the YouTube star had done it herself. There were small mistakes, just little things that might drive some people nuts. But for Ricky, it was good to feel like somebody actually cared. It was fully captioned, mixed case, full words, punctuation and all, and I was like, that's awesome. I would love to see more of that. ["Soulin' back with Chris Barouba, Hey, Chris.
它们并不完全专业，看起来像是这位YouTube明星自己做的。有一些小错误，只是一些可能会让某些人抓狂的小事。但对于瑞奇来说，感觉有人真的在乎是件好事。它有完整的字幕，大小写混合，完整的单词，标点符号等等，我就想，那太棒了。我很乐意看到更多这样的内容。["与克里斯·巴鲁贝一起回来，嘿，克里斯。
Hey, Roman. So do you use closed captioning? Because I use it all the time. For everything, just all the time. Yeah. Everything I watch on Netflix, everything I watch on everywhere at this point that it's available. Yeah.
嘿，罗曼。那么你使用隐藏式字幕吗？因为我一直都在用。为了所有事情，就是一直都在用。是的。我在Netflix上看的每件事，此时此刻在任何地方只要有字幕我都会看。是的。
So why do you use them? Well, I use them because I get confused easily. I don't use them for accessibility reasons, but I'm certainly not the only hearing person using closed captions. There's this one recent survey. It was more than 1200 people, which found half of Americans are using closed captions most of the time. And that number is actually much higher for Gen Z. That's like 70%. So it's not just people who have accessibility needs. And so what do you think so many people
那你为什么使用它们？嗯，我使用它们是因为我很容易感到困惑。我不是因为无障碍原因使用它们，但我肯定不是唯一使用隐藏式字幕的听力正常的人。最近有一项调查。超过1200人，发现一半的美国人大部分时间都在使用隐藏式字幕。而这个数字对于Z世代来说实际上要高得多。大约是70%。所以不仅仅是有无障碍需求的人。那么你认为为什么这么多人
are using closed captions? Yeah, there's a lot of reasons. I mean, one is that captions are just normal now, right? Like especially for younger viewers. You see this in a lot of TikTok and Instagram videos that they have open captions, which means that the captions are on all the time. You can't turn them off.
都在使用隐藏式字幕？是的，有很多原因。我的意思是，一个是字幕现在很正常，对吧？就像对于年轻观众来说。你在很多TikTok和Instagram视频中看到这一点，它们有开放式字幕，这意味着字幕一直都在。你不能关掉它们。
And this kind of an aesthetic choice, it's just become a thing you see in a lot of videos. But going back to the survey, the big reason, there's one big reason that most people cite for using the closed captions and the big reason is that audio sounds muddled. So people are saying, modern dialogue is more confusing, it's harder to follow, and that's why they like
而这种审美选择，已经成为你在很多视频中看到的一种东西。但回到调查，主要原因，大多数人引用使用隐藏式字幕的一个大原因，大原因就是音频听起来很模糊。所以人们说，现代对话更令人困惑，更难跟随，这就是为什么他们如此喜欢
the captions so much. Yeah, I have noticed this. I call this the Christopher Nolan problem because he has a pension for having mumbly low-key but very good actors in his movies next to large booming sounds. Yeah, I mean, I love Tom Hardy, but Tom Hardy, like I don't think I've ever heard him deliver a line straight, deliver a line intelligibly. And so why do you think that is? I mean, why is dialogue harder to follow now?
字幕的原因。是的，我注意到了这一点。我称之为“克里斯托弗·诺兰问题”，因为他有在电影中让口齿不清、低调但非常优秀的演员在巨大的轰鸣声旁边表演的倾向。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢汤姆·哈迪（Tom Hardy），但汤姆·哈迪，我不认为我曾经听过他清晰地念出一句台词。那么你认为这是为什么呢？我的意思是，为什么现在的对话更难跟随了？
Well, there is actually a journalist who looked into this recently. All of my friends were like, I can't understand anything that anybody's saying. And I was like, man, I really wish that there is an answer to this. So that's Edward Vega. He is a video producer for the website Vox.
嗯，实际上有一位记者最近调查了这个问题。我所有的朋友都说，我听不懂任何人说的任何话。我就说，伙计，我真的希望有一个答案。所以那是爱德华·维加（Edward Vega）。他是网站Vox的视频制作人。
And he decided to look into this. Actually, the catalyst for him was watching the movie movie The King of Staten Island with Pete Davidson. Okay. It's the emotional height of the movie and he says like, it's hard. I think it'll always be hard. I think it'll always be hard. But he mumbles it and he says it so quietly that like, I swear to God, I went back three times. So Ed did this big investigation and he discovered like, this is real, this is not in our heads.
他决定调查一下。实际上，他的催化剂是看皮特·戴维森（Pete Davidson）主演的电影《史泰登岛国王》（The King of Staten Island）。好吧。这是电影的情感高潮，他说“这很难。我想这永远都会很难。我想这永远都会很难。”但他嘟囔着说，而且他说得那么小声，以至于我发誓，我回去看了三遍。所以埃德做了这个大调查，他发现，这是真的，这不是我们的幻觉。
And there's a couple of reasons this is happening. Okay, what are the reasons? So a big one is dynamic range. So basically, if your movie has voices in it and your movie also has explosions, you have to make sure the explosions are louder than the voices, right? Like, I mean, that seems obvious. But it's something where the explosions have to be quite a bit louder so that they have an impact. When you're mixing a movie, if your explosion is going to be the loudest thing in the mix,
而且发生这种情况有几个原因。好吧，原因是什么？所以一个很大的原因是动态范围。所以基本上，如果你的电影里有人声，而你的电影里也有爆炸声，你必须确保爆炸声比人声大，对吧？我的意思是，这似乎很明显。但爆炸声必须大得多，这样它们才有冲击力。当你混音电影时，如果你的爆炸声将是混音中最响亮的东西，
then your dialogue can't be that loud. And so you have to choose which one do you want to move? Do you want to move the dialogue down or do you want to move the explosion up? One of these issues, it is this idea of dynamic range. It's balancing things out so that the explosion has more impact as a result, the dialogue suffers. So another big issue is the rise of naturalism in performances. If an actor mumbles their way through a line, if their words start to run together, there's nothing I can do to fix that. So this is Austin Olivia Kendrick.
那么你的对话就不可能那么大声。所以你必须选择你想要移动哪一个？你是想把对话调低，还是想把爆炸声调高？这些问题之一，就是这个动态范围的概念。它是平衡事物，以便爆炸声有更大的冲击力，结果，对话就受损了。所以另一个大问题是表演中自然主义的兴起。如果一个演员嘟囔着念完一句台词，如果他们的单词开始连在一起，我无法做任何事情来修复它。所以这是奥斯汀·奥利维亚·肯德里克（Austin Olivia Kendrick）。
I currently work as a dialogue editor at Warner Brothers. Now, I'm wondering about his television specifically. So Edward Vega very nicely introduced the two of us and Austin says movie technology has changed and as a result actors performances have changed as well. Back in the day when when sound technology was first introduced to film that technology was very kind of primitive. The only real option when it came to filming movies with sound was you were on a sound stage, a microphone was planted above your head and the actors had to stand there and project into the microphone. But as sound technology evolved and all the sudden we have wireless microphones that we can place on actors, that kind of loosened
我目前在华纳兄弟担任对话编辑。现在，我特别好奇电视方面。所以爱德华·维加非常好地介绍了我们俩，奥斯汀说电影技术已经改变，结果演员的表演也发生了变化。回到过去，当声音技术首次引入电影时，那种技术非常原始。当涉及到拍摄有声电影时，唯一的真正选择是你必须在摄影棚里，麦克风安装在你的头顶上方，演员必须站在那里对着麦克风发声。但随着声音技术的发展，突然间我们有了可以放在演员身上的无线麦克风，这那种方式放松了
up actors performances. They now no longer have to stand in one spot and project and gave them more freedom and kind of pushed them more into a naturalistic style of performance. And that subsequently could mean mumbling. So there you go, technology, the second thing, that's why you're getting these mumbly performances. Yeah, but for decades and decades, I know that they've been doing dialogue replacement where an actor comes in after the fact and records dialogue to make it more clear. Right, yeah, that's ADR. And I did talk to Austin about this.
演员的表演。他们现在不再需要站在一个地方发声，这给了他们更多的自由，并把他们更多地推向了一种自然主义的表演风格。而这随后可能意味着嘟囔。所以就这样，技术，第二件事，这就是为什么你会得到这些嘟囔的表演。是的，但几十年来，我知道他们一直在做对话替换，演员在事后进来并录制对话以使其更清晰。对，是的，那是ADR。我确实和奥斯汀谈过这个问题。
And she says doing ADR is actually pretty difficult, especially when the dialogue is very mumbly. When we bring actors in to re-record lines, they have to match their performance to the way that their lips are moving on screen. And if they mumbled their way through that take, their lips aren't moving very much. So if they come in and re-record a line with a lot more diction and a lot more separation between the words, that's not going to match. The last issue, and this might be the biggest one, this is something called down mixing.
她说做ADR实际上相当困难，特别是当对话非常嘟囔时。当我们带演员进来重新录制台词时，他们必须使他们的表演与他们在屏幕上嘴唇移动的方式相匹配。如果他们在那个镜头中嘟囔着念完，他们的嘴唇移动得并不多。所以如果他们进来并用更多的发音和单词之间更多的分离重新录制一句台词，那将无法匹配。最后一个问题，这可能是最大的一个，这就是所谓的“下混”（down mixing）。
So this is the idea that a lot of movies and some TV shows are mixed for the best possible sound system, right? Many of them are mixed for Dolby Atmos. That's the special sound system. You get in certain theaters that has 128 channels. So you can mix something in a very, very specific particular way. And then after you've mixed it for the best sound system, you have to remix it for other platforms like a television or a phone. And that is when you start to get into trouble. You're taking 128 channels and you're compressing that down into different formats with lesser channels.
所以这个想法是，许多电影和一些电视节目是为最好的音响系统混音的，对吧？它们中的许多是为杜比全景声（Dolby Atmos）混音的。那是特殊的音响系统。你在某些剧院里得到的有128个声道。所以你可以以一种非常、非常具体的方式混音。然后在你为最好的音响系统混音之后，你必须为其他平台（如电视或手机）重新混音。而那就是你开始遇到麻烦的时候。你正在把128个声道压缩成具有较少声道的不同格式。
And most of the time when you're watching something out of your TV, unless you have a surround system, it's going to be stereo or mono. So if you're going from 128 down to two or down to one, it gets muddy. It gets a lot more year. So lots of movies and TV shows, you know, they're getting mixed in the sound system, then they're getting down mixed for other formats. And Austin says, usually the down mix at the end, that's the last thing they do in the editing process.
而且大多数时候，当你从电视上看东西时，除非你有环绕声系统，否则它将是立体声或单声道。所以如果你从128降到2或降到1，它就会变得浑浊。它会变得更加模糊。所以很多电影和电视节目，你知道，它们在音响系统中混音，然后它们为其他格式进行下混。而奥斯汀说，通常最后的下混，那是他们在编辑过程中做的最后一件事。
And sometimes they don't put quite the same care and effort into it that they would for the initial mix for a movie theater. Yeah, a lot of the times when it comes to that kind of down mixing, often studios do not want to spend the money because ultimately time is money and re-recording mixers are very expensive to hire for that extra time, you know. So oftentimes they want to put a little money into that area as possible. So, Roman, there you have it. It's down mixing, it's naturalistic performances, it's this dynamic range issue.
有时他们并没有投入与电影院初始混音相同的关心和努力。是的，很多时候当涉及到那种下混时，工作室通常不想花钱，因为最终时间就是金钱，重新录制混音师非常昂贵，无法雇佣他们进行额外的时间，你知道。所以通常他们想在那个领域投入尽可能少的钱。所以，罗曼，这就是原因。是下混，是自然主义的表演，是这个动态范围的问题。
Those are some of the reasons why you did not understand the movie Tenet by Christopher Moore. Well, they're not the only reason why I didn't understand Tenet, but that helps. Yeah, the time travel stuff also contributes to it, I guess. There's a lot going on working against Tenet being a comprehensible film. So, Roman, I have to say before we go, the video by Edward Vega on Vox,
这些是你没有听懂克里斯托弗·诺兰（Christopher Nolan）的电影《信条》（Tenet）的一些原因。好吧，它们不是我没听懂《信条》的唯一原因，但这有帮助。是的，时间旅行的东西也对此有贡献，我想。有很多事情在阻碍《信条》成为一部可理解的电影。所以，罗曼，在我们要走之前我必须说，爱德华·维加在Vox上的视频，
it goes into so much more depth on this topic. It's wonderful. I hope everybody checks it out. And also, I hope everyone checks out Austin Livia Kendrick's TikTok, if you use that platform. She explains movie sound and it is so fascinating. It's awesome. All right, thank you so much, Chris. Thanks, Roman.
它在这个话题上深入得多。它太棒了。我希望每个人都去看看。而且，我也希望每个人都去看看奥斯汀·奥利维亚·肯德里克的TikTok，如果你使用那个平台的话。她解释了电影声音，这太迷人了。太棒了。好的，非常感谢你，克里斯。谢谢，罗曼。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barube, with editorial input from Linda Besner. She originally wrote about this topic for the Atlantic magazine. Linda is writing a book about people and their complicated relationships with money, look for it soon, at a bookstore near you. The story was edited by Kelly Prime, original music by Swan Riel, sound mix by Martin Gonzalez, fact checking by Graham Haysha, who couldn't independently verify that Crocomoli loved Guacamole, but we assured him that this was true
本周的《99% Invisible》由Chris Barube制作，Linda Besner提供了编辑建议。她最初为《大西洋》杂志撰写了关于这个主题的文章。Linda正在写一本关于人们与金钱之间复杂关系的书，敬请期待，不久后将在您附近的书店上架。本期故事由Kelly Prime编辑，原创音乐由Swan Riel创作，声音混音由Martin Gonzalez完成，事实核查由Graham Haysha负责，他无法独立证实Crocomoli是否喜欢鳄梨酱，但我们向他保证这是真的。
and we went with it anyway. Kurt Colstet is our digital director, our intern is a Vante Nomear. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Christopher Johnson, Jason D'Leone, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars.
我们还是采用了这个说法。Kurt Colstet是我们的数字总监，我们的实习生是Vante Nomear。团队其他成员包括高级编辑Delaney Hall、Christopher Johnson、Jason D'Leone、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Leigh、Jacob Moltenado Medina、Joe Rosenberg，以及我，Roman Mars。
The 99% of his below-go was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Caroline, Minks, and Ann Valentine. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
《99% Invisible》由Stefan Lawrence创立。本周特别感谢Caroline、Minks和Ann Valentine。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼，坐落在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。您可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PiOrg. Or on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99p i dot org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PiOrg。也可以在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上找到我们。您可以在99pi.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目链接，以及《99% Invisible》的所有往期剧集。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。